maze free playstation plus games may
have leaked and activision is banning
more cheaters
once again it appears that the next
batch of free games for playstation plus
subscribers has leaked early the leak
comes from deals lab a french gaming
site that has correctly reported ps plus
lineups for more than six months now
according to the leak the ps plus lineup
for may 2022 includes fifa 2022 one of
the most popular sports games in the
world the second game is tribes of
midgard an action rpg designed to be
played cooperatively alongside friends
the game features a dangerous world
filled with giant mysterious enemies and
an overarching story that nods back to
ragnarok the third is curse of the dead
gods a more traditional action roguelike
set in a dangerous temple filled with
increasingly challenging enemies may's
batch of free games could be the last
before the revamped playstation plus
subscription launches in june with three
tiers those tiers include essential
extra and premium and all three tiers
will still include monthly freebies and
speaking of sony's information coming
out early a new linkedin listing has
provided more clues to the unannounced
remake of the last of us credits for qa
testing and development support plus
level point of contact for unannounced
remake project were found on the resume
of a naughty dog qa employee as spotted
by eurogamer the page also has qa
testing and development support on
environment design for unannounced
multiplayer projects listed on the page
another sign that the remake could
feature an online component and this
isn't the only last of us project in
development as leaks from earlier in the
year uncovered the apparent existence of
a director's cut of the last of us part
2 while naughty dog's neil druckmann
said at ces 2022 that the studio was
dying to show off the multiple games it
had in development but okay now let's
switch from leaks to cheaters call of
duty's new anti-cheat software ricochet
is now available for call of duty
vanguard the driver includes all
upgrades since it launched in 2021 for
the battle royale game as well as new
ones for vanguard the new updates are
also being added to ricochet for war
zone to bring parody for anti-cheat
drivers across both titles activision
also clarified that anyone banned for
cheating in warzone or vanguard will be
deleted from leaderboards what's more
the publishers shed new light on a
further tactic it's taking to give
cheaters a hard time cloaking is a new
system that makes players identified as
cheaters unable to see opposing players
in the game additionally activision
announced it had banned more than 54 000
accounts since the announcement of 90
000 bans at the end of march finally the
publisher said it encourages players to
continue to report cheaters because
activision's own tools can only do so
much as cheaters continue to find new
ways to get a leg up hit the comment
section let me know if you're a cheater
and we'll see you tomorrow
you